hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that just finished from
round six of this year's European Team
Championship it is Nicholas todoro of
Greece versus azer Bean's first board
that is of course Tamar rajabov and it's
a game unlike we've seen in a long time
uh really really incredible features
known line and then into going into some
known Theory uh but uh it was obviously
too much for for por rajabov so let's
check out what happened here Nicholas
had the white pieces and he opened with
Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to E5 Knight F3
and Knight to F6 going for the pet of
Defense uh D4 and now Knight captures on
e4 this is the soalin its attack against
the Petro Knight captures on e4 H and
now Bishop to D4 is the main line here D
captures on E5 is what Nicholas goes for
here we have Bishop to C5 uh going uh
after df2 pawn and now Bishop to C4 uh
just going uh well after Bishop captures
an F7 it's a it's a fairly known line
and although it looks like a weird
position to have white already allowing
black to play Knight or Bishop captures
an F2 it has been played by some very
strong players nepo played it against
Aron abdat played against dud alas he
played it against giri uh and so on so
here Knight captures an F2 if you're
wondering about Bishop captures an F2 uh
it's losing or very very close to losing
for black point is that after we move
the king now how are you dealing with uh
anything just uh well bar Queen D5 just
attacking your knight and you will have
to move it whatever you play let's say
castle just Queen D5 there's no defense
you either move the Knight and lose the
bishop or you move the bishop and lose
the Knight so what you could do here is
play something like maybe D5 uh to trade
of Queens but even that will not help
you for example captures captures and
captures and now F5 point being that now
if the Knight is captured you play Pawn
captures and attack the Knight on F3 but
you can simply go e captures on F6 alasa
and then after Knight captures you're
attacking the bishop yes but after King
captures and Knight captures on D5
although the material is equal white
will still be winning this because of
Rook to E1 with check so that's all been
uh seen before and now if you go here uh
then just Rook D1 followed by C4 and if
you go to the f file uh will not help
you Knight E5 check for example King to
F6 and now B3 will open up this diagonal
and uh White will be uh White will be
winning this
uh so that's why after Bishop to C4 no
one ever plays Bishop captures on F2 the
move is Knight captures on F2 again
pretty standard stuff uh and now we have
Bishop captures on F7 King captures and
now of course Queen to D5 check to win
the bishop on C5 King to G6 Queen
captures on C5 and now Knight captures
on H1 and now if you count to the
material uh you can see that um the each
uh player has six pawns but rajabov is
up a full Rook he has two Rooks um
Nicholas has one but his King is on G6
so it's definitely a trade-off and he
just continues Knight to C3 there's time
to pick up the Knight on on H1 uh it's
not really going anywhere F2 and G3 are
guarded and now Pawn to H6 you know that
um once that Queen starts checking you
you want to hide the king as soon as
possible so here uh Queen to C4 is a
known move Queen to D4 is a known move
and queen to D5 is a known move so those
are the known moves all three aimed at
attacking the black king uh you can't
really deliver a check from C5 but here
we have Knight to D5 and it is now as of
move 10 that we have a completely new
game so rajabu has to figure out how to
deal with this yes the C7 Pawn is being
attacked but you're not really worried
about that you're upper Rook you're
worried about not getting checkmated
here so of course he starts with Rook to
E8 and now we have Queen to D4 now uh if
if you go for Knight captures on C7 to
uh win The Rook here it's not really in
the spirit of the position or anything
and black can just play D6 attack the
queen you cannot capture as The Rook is
on E8 and once the queen moves you can
even play Pawn to D5 and now okay you
will if if you go uh Knight captures or
if you go Queen to C5 then even Knight
to A6 attacks the Knight and the queen
so you don't have time to capture the
rook and if you play Knight captures on
D5 then just King to H7 and black has
now defended and everything is perfectly
fine so after this Rook to E8 move Queen
to D4 was played adding more defense to
the E5 pawn and now Shifting the queen
to help out with the attack of the black
king and rajabu just escapes King to H7
he says thank you I'm up a rook I'm just
going to leave and now I now I will
definitely start developing my pieces
because we know that this is not the way
to actually play chess uh but Nicholas
says nope not going to happen Bishop
captures on H6 and what do you what do
you play when you see a move like this I
mean this is a serious classical game uh
in a very prestigious tournament known
as the European team championship and
and uh I mean you you're playing against
the grandm but you you are Tam rajabov I
mean you're you're an absolute monster
on the chess board you you're a legend
you're I mean you've defeated everyone
you You' defeated G kasaro when you were
16 with the black pieces with with an
amazing Knight sacrifice so how is this
happening what is Bishop captures on H6
and uh uh C can you take the bishop uh
Well turns out no you can't uh the only
way to play this I mean you can just not
right away you have to play Knight to C6
first uh attack the queen and once the
queen moves now you will play Rook to f8
attack the queen again and once the
queen moves again now you'll play G
captures on H6 and now it's basically a
draw Queen to E4 with check you're going
to play King to G7 and it's going to be
a repetition because if you if you move
uh the king away then Queen to G6 will
uh give you a lot of problems so with
best play this is just a draw for black
there's nothing more here but Raj said
all right G captures an H6 it's probably
still some kind of a draw uh and now
comes uh the only move that wins the
game and that is I'm not going to tell
you what it is feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Nicholas
while I give you a couple of seconds and
maybe you also will uh receive the
prestigious award after the
video so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on uh uh
playing in in the Spirit of of the olden
days and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is queenside
castles that's the way to do it and now
you have another attacker enter entering
the game and there is nothing more to be
done here for black rajabu played Rook
to E6 but now comes Knight to F6 with
check and it doesn't help if you capture
here point is that after you capture and
capture and uh you you you don't have
anything developed here you have to
develop something uh Queen E4 check for
example and now okay this is uh guarded
by the pawn you you have to move either
to G8 and then this comes with check or
you go here and now comes Queen to G6
going after Queen captures on H6 uh and
after the queen defends that now you
will play Rook to D4 that's why castling
was important so you can go for this
Rook lift and now there's no defense
against Rook H4 and Rook captures on H6
um either Checkmate or winning the black
queen so that's uh that's the reason
after Knight to F6 you cannot capture
the Knight so King to h8 was played but
now comes the only winning move and I'm
sure you guys found this one when you
played castles that is Knight to H4 now
the other Knight comes to G6 and then
the black king is completely doomed Pawn
to D6 finally open up opening up this
light Square bishop and now Queen to F4
going after the uh Pawn here uh but you
can't really uh defend it in a good way
King to G7 was played now Queen to G4
check King to h8 and now again Knight to
G6 with check we have King to G7 and now
Knight to f8 with check and he was in
this position un move 19 yes move 19
you've heard that correctly that Tam
rajab resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here it doesn't
matter if you capture the Knight or if
you play a king to F7 it's exactly the
same Queen to G8 check King to E7 and
now Queen to G7 will be Checkmate so
absolutely incredible incredible game H
it's well it's very very hard to believe
he was played in 2020 three in a
European team championship against world
number 16 at the time this game was
played on the live ratings list Tam
rajabov but yeah look at this position
it's like um it's like textbook what not
to do with black and of course rajabov
knows this it's just that uh it it
happens I mean you know that this is a
draw it's a draw it's a draw it's a draw
and then all of a sudden that Bishop
captures on H6 moves comes uh and it's
not a draw anymore I mean it is you just
can't take the bishop but look at this
undeveloped UND veloped undeveloped
undeveloped overdeveloped also what Rook
on E6 Knight on H1 capturing The Rook
this is uh this is really textbook
something you would see uh out of the
maybe era of Paul morphy and Adolf
Anderson absolutely absolutely
incredible stuff and that's why after a
very long time we are awarding Nicholas
with the most prestigious award on this
channel and that is of course the morphe
head there you go uh the morphe head
head has been awarded after a long time
and I mean what a game now okay you you
might even say that um considering the
strength of the of the opponent Teo
rajabov this could also contest for the
game of the year uh but I don't know if
is it too short to be considered a game
of the year I mean 19 moves and it just
uh I have no idea what to think of this
game I'm still under the impression so
what do you guys think what what what
happened here and how did how did
Nicolas take down uh someone as strong
as as rajabov in 19 moves with with such
such amazing morphes play uh but yeah
interestingly both him and stava are
from Greece so Greece is having some
incredible games um you know over the
course of the week uh we'll see what
what will follow uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh
incredible stuff um I know I'm saying
incredible a lot but this this is I mean
this is really just o o
inspiring uh I would like to thank kodu
chess club um Chen boho and siik nck
Donald Duncan Parker Andreas rosental
and David gasparian for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with more incredible
games like this one thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your
day